welcome to this video playing son Clara
CMOS now you seem us from from Spain it
is oops I got requests to play them 97
lined up um cats sometimes called the
cap off line or Smith's loveline age six
now is the famous cos power of game
where the computer took only six um now
aged six is this I think it is yeah here
you can do it make up a makeup theory am
so long as we go here quinces and I
think you play like this Queen c7 and
then quite often black doesn't castle I
wonder if this is one of those positions
but then probably long castle is not too
bad why not
hmm yeah probably really g3 hmm now this
weekend's the diagonal but I understand
he didn't want to didn't want to allow a
simplification with Bishop f4 however if
this was good is another matter the
simplification hmm I take with the Queen
and because i want to control me five
yeah I thought yeah I thought I can just
the channel is not think he just see him
I thought this was good no attacking f2
entered rook rookie to their special by
three maybe has some technical way to to
play like Bishop f4 or something like
that
we should a fire it's interesting if i
take it should be five checking at
Bishop takes g7 he gets the g7 porn and
the age six porn but i think i'll be
sure before i can play king ahead just
ignoring that ok and now here check yes
but i have e five amongst others i ah he
has got rookie five okay if I just go
here when he cannot play Bishop before
at all because of the week back rank
what I'm not so sure of if maybe in this
in a scenario where I capture and he
yeah like this Bishop takes Bishop takes
he's got Bishop f3 coming which looks
like a bit of a bit of an annoying move
you know what i do i do it differently I
just I don't take the exchange I just do
it like that and now this is this is
just a pawn but it's a very clear pole I
get my night back and he's got a bad
structure three Pawn islands against two
rooks it to have got Roxy eight so no
problem yes f6 I thought okay this is a
slight slight problem I don't want to
weaken my pawn structure okay but I have
rope yet okay I don't need to play any
don't need to play a five I can play
Mookie 8e five he would have played
default quickly open up the position
this I didn't didn't want to allow ok so
here what is he doing octave form okay I
need to activate the night get it back
into play look g5g five it's not a known
problem okay use the King night can
always go to g5 p.m.
f5 f5 oh no f5 g5 yeah why not
I forgot that yes this one or should I
should I play yeah e5 I can play you
five takes Knight eggs well it's not too
too convincing 95 Scott luckily five
yeah I could have I think I could have
had it much easier
ok check
mmm g6 problem
yeah I don't think I did something
really terrible it just feels like it
there was some some easier way to do it
yeah he doesn't have anything else then
just take him really okay
no Jake's what else check
now I can go here or is there something
better
hmm
yes this is this is actually pretty
clear just take g4 next it's all with
the temple yeah its Lucas offside
checks
check time warning check check
check
check
drive no time at all check draw offered
draw offered up Ron yeah just guys
actually taking the draw witches yeah I
have not winning this is so just just
super embarrassing I mean say every move
winsome night a check everything wins
how did I spoil that you know maybe I
should just take G fund yeah just take
it and and push the pawns this already
is missus is just just nonsense Jack
yeah it's the 30 seconds against a
minute this doesn't help but a very bad
end game I mean I'm not winning this is
just terrible it's just check night f 2
nite g4s the easiest yeah okay it's
useless to analyze I just played this
like like an brain-dead night f2 can I
have two is the easiest year just don't
check check check Pierre chase King
somewhere here and white resigns I just
have this pawns okay thanks for watching